This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Ready open on Roman? Open? Go. When I'm not making radio, I listen to a lot of radio. More than most people can imagine. Set it down clock for 4.30 please. My earbuds are constantly launched in my ears so that I can press play and listen to radio at any moment
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。罗曼准备开麦了吗？开麦了吗？开始。不做广播的时候，我听很多广播。比大多数人想象的还要多。请把倒计时器设为 4 分钟 30 秒。我的耳朵里一直塞着耳机，这样我就可以随时按播放键收听广播
that doesn't require me to talk or listen to an actual human being in the real world. Alright, well now is the moment in our show where we endorse. Manage in every site by Tori Moutia. Audio news paper for a visual world. Sure! Answer me this podcast.com The show is produced by speaking into microphones. Hello, it's Jason.
不需要我在现实世界中与真人交谈或倾听。好吧，现在是节目中我们进行推荐的时刻。由托里·穆蒂亚（Tori Moutia）管理的 Manage in every site。面向视觉世界的音频报纸。当然！Answer me this podcast.com 本节目是通过对着麦克风说话制作的。你好，我是杰森。
Yes. Hello, Jason. Hello. Scan by to open Julia. Whether I'm walking on secret stairs or doing the dishes, open or Car, car, car, car, car, car. Standby to open, Julia. Whether I'm walking on secret stairs or doing the dishes, open or driving the car. You're there, but you're somewhere else too. We producers aspire to create driveway moments, TM. Story's so good that listeners can't leave their car
你好。你好，杰森。你好。准备开麦，朱莉娅。无论我是走在神秘的阶梯上还是在洗碗，开麦，或者汽车，汽车，汽车，汽车，汽车，汽车。准备开麦，朱莉娅。无论我是走在神秘的阶梯上还是在洗碗，开麦，或者开着车。你在那里，但你也在别的地方。我们制作人渴望创造“行车时刻”（TM）。精彩的故事让听众欲罢不能，甚至离不开汽车
until they're over. I think part of what makes a driveway moment is the end of that moment. When you realize what time it is, you could have been staring at a clock all along, but for a while, for once, it had no power over you. That time distortion field is when a public radio secret, awesome powers, which is why it is such a shock when those of us go from being radio listeners to radio producers, like me and my friend Julia Barton here.
直到节目结束。我认为造就“行车时刻”的部分原因在于那个时刻的结束。当你意识到时间的时候，你本可以一直盯着时钟，但有一段时间，破天荒地，它对你失去了控制。这种时间扭曲场正是公共广播的一大秘密超能力，这就是为什么当我们在广播听众和广播制作人之间转换身份时，会感到如此震惊，就像我和我的朋友朱莉娅·巴顿（Julia Barton）一样。
The audience is hearing this. It's hard to believe he's not nervous. But this is what radio sounds like on the inside. I'm 32 seconds short of what I'm supposed to have. So what I'll do is I'll just play 15 seconds of this song. And then while I'll play the 15 seconds,... I visited NPR's headquarters in Washington, D.C. and sat in on the live role of all things considered. Their flagship afternoon news magazine show.
听众听到了这些。很难相信他一点都不紧张。但这就是广播内部听起来的样子。我比应有的时长短了 32 秒。所以我要做的就是播放这首歌的 15 秒。然后在我播放这 15 秒的同时，……我参观了 NPR 位于华盛顿特区的总部，并旁听了旗舰午后新闻杂志节目《综合报道》（All Things Considered）的现场直播。
There are clocks all over the studios. Big red digital clocks. Huge round analog clocks. Special software and calculators. Time calculators. We're 60 plus 60 equals 2 0 0. Hi. Met, uh, when one in the only to play 15 seconds but you wrapped up 45 seconds or so now I have to play a long time is it okay?
工作室里到处都是时钟。巨大的红色数字时钟。巨大的圆形模拟时钟。特殊的软件和计算器。时间计算器。我们是 60 加 60 等于 2 0 0。嗨。梅特，呃，原本只打算播放 15 秒，但你提前了 45 秒左右收尾，现在我必须播放很长时间，这样行吗？
Yeah, I mean, we're gonna have a choice really. Do we have enough to dead roll it? I don't think so. Monica is Stativia, directs all things considered four days a week. To me, it's the scariest job in the world. That fear is built in to the design of a program like all things considered. It's the show clock. The show has a set clock.
行吧，我的意思是，我们其实别无选择。我们有足够的垫播内容吗？我觉得没有。莫妮卡·斯塔蒂维亚（Monica Stativia）每周四天担任《综合报道》的导播。对我来说，这是世界上最可怕的工作。这种恐惧深深植根于像《综合报道》这样节目的设计中。那就是节目时钟。节目有一个固定的时钟。
It's a template from which it almost never varies. Every show that broadcasts or aspires to broadcasts in the public radio system has a clock. Basically, it looks like a pie. It's round and sliced in lots of weird ways. Some of the slices are very thin. There's 59 seconds for the program opening. We call that the billboard. 14 seconds for the funding credits. A fatter slice is 5 minutes for the newscast. The biggest slices are littered A, B, C, and D, and they are the segments. That's where the stories and interviews live, and they have to fit together. One minute to close.
这是一个几乎从不改变的模板。每一个在公共广播系统中播出或渴望播出的节目都有一个时钟。基本上，它看起来像一个派。它是圆的，被切成了许多奇怪的切片。有些切片非常薄。节目开场有 59 秒。我们称之为公告牌（billboard）。14 秒的资助鸣谢。一个稍大的切片是 5 分钟的新闻快讯。最大的切片标记为 A、B、C 和 D，它们是各个板块。故事和采访就在这里进行，它们必须完美契合。距离结束还有一分钟。
I remember I was very scared of the clock. Me ears, tu figurine out completely. The clock is your master for the two hours the show rolls out. Everything has to be ready. Seignants can't run long by even a second, because most of the local stations are automated to cut off the national program where the clock says they can. These times are called posts. You have to hit the post. Nothing can go wrong. But of course, things go wrong every day. Someone reads too long and interview runs too
我记得我非常害怕这个时钟。我的耳朵，完全在拼命琢磨。在节目播出的两个小时里，时钟就是你的主宰。一切都必须准备就绪。板块甚至不能超长哪怕一秒钟，因为大多数地方电台都是自动化控制，会在时钟指定的位置切断国家节目的信号。这些时间点被称为卡点（posts）。你必须准时卡点。什么都不能出差错。但当然，每天都有事情出错。有人读得太久，采访时间太
short. You might hear the dreaded dead air or someone rushing at the post. Then listeners can hear the clock. He who can't be named in public radio. And then the spell is broken. When you look at this document, you see something very regimented and we've talked about how it is very regimented in terms of things happening at a particular second. But the goal is for people not to really know it's there. That's Greg Dixon, who also directs all things considered.
短。你可能会听到可怕的死寂无声（dead air），或者有人在卡点时仓促收尾。然后听众就能听到时钟的声音。那个在公共广播中不能被提及的人。然后魔咒就被打破了。当你看着这份文档时，你会看到高度军事化管理的东西，我们已经讨论过它在某个特定秒数发生事情方面是多么的军事化管理。但我们的目标是让人们并不真的察觉到它的存在。这是格雷克·迪克森（Greg Dixon）说的，他也是《综合报道》的导播。
But like most show directors, he never actually looks at the diagram of the program clock. This visual representation was hard for me to reference quickly. I had a piece of paper where I lined out every single time when things started and how long they were gonna be. It was my cheat sheet and I brought it into the studio every day. And according to Greg Dixon, he brought it in much longer than he actually needed it. Until it was in Tatters, but those crypt sheets and you will find them everywhere in broadcast are a bridge to the place where the clock actually lives. You can wake up, wake us up in the middle of the night and we can be like 59, 5, 28, 12, 28, 128, like 7, 48. We know we can go down the entire hour without ever stopping because we know it, we know
但像大多数节目导播一样，他实际上从来不看节目时钟的图表。这个视觉表征对我来说很难快速参考。我有一张纸，上面列出了事情开始的每一个时间点以及它们的时长。那是我的小抄，我每天都把它带进工作室。据格雷克·迪克森说，他带它的时间远比实际需要的时间要长。直到纸张破烂不堪，但那些小抄——你会在广播界到处找到它们——通往了时钟实际存在的那个地方。你可以在半夜叫醒我们，我们就能说出 59, 5, 28, 12, 28, 128，就像 7, 48。我们知道我们可以一气呵成地播完整整一个小时而从不停顿，因为我们对它了如指掌，我们对它
it by heart and of course we had dreams about it. An NPR they're called director's dreams. You lose control. You cannot regain back control. And you have lost sense of how much time is left in the segment, how much time is left for the piece. And usually it's like the worst panic attack. And you wake up and you're sweating. And you can't believe you just get another
烂熟于心，当然我们也会做关于它的梦。在 NPR，它们被称为“导播之梦”。你失去了控制。你无法重新夺回控制权。你已经失去了对板块中还剩多少时间、稿件中还剩多少时间的感知。通常这就像是最糟糕的恐慌发作。然后你醒来，浑身是汗。简直不敢相信自己又做了一个
direct stream. I've had those where I'm on the board announcing morning edition on KALW and the sliders don't do anything and the buttons just don't look right and to rather than try anything I'm just paralyzed with fear. Oh yeah in my dream I'm doing a newscast with no copy and I just have to talk and talk and talk and talk And talk like an idiot until the clock goes down and I haven't even seen a downclock in ages No podcast there is no time scarcity no interlocking gears of local and national broadcasts and that changes Everything but we also make a version of this show that fits inside the NPR clock, the C-Signative Morning Edition to be exact.
导播梦。我也做过这样的梦，我在 KALW 主持《早间新闻》（Morning Edition），推子毫无反应，按钮看起来也不对劲，比起尝试任何操作，我只是被恐惧吓得瘫痪了。哦，是的，在我的梦里，我播报新闻时没有稿子，我只能不停地像个傻瓜一样说啊说啊说啊说，直到时钟走完，我已经好久没见过倒计时钟了。播客里没有时间稀缺性，没有地方台和国家台广播相互咬合的齿轮，这改变了一切。但我们也制作了该节目的一版，它能够塞进 NPR 的时钟里，确切地说，是符合《早间新闻》的时长标准。
Four minutes and 30 seconds exactly. Over by 143. So I'm gonna have to figure out a way to take all of these ideas early, some fraction of these ideas and cram them into a show that's less than five minutes. And sometimes that really, really sucks. But you'd be surprised, though, often, I actually really like the brief radio version of this program.
整整 4 分钟 30 秒。1 分 43 秒时结束。所以我得想办法把所有这些想法——或者说这些想法的一小部分——塞进一个不到五分钟的节目里。有时这真的很糟糕。不过你会惊讶地发现，通常我其实真的很喜欢这个节目的简短广播版。
The first time I really internalized the difference between doing radio and doing podcasts was when people would tell me that they wanted my stories to be longer. In the entire decade of radio, I produced prior to this podcast, no editor has ever asked me to go longer. Yeah, and I was your editor Roman, and I can vouch for that. You were so mean to me.
我第一次真正内化广播和播客的区别，是当人们告诉我他们希望我的故事更长一些。在我制作这个播客之前的整整十年广播生涯中，没有任何一个编辑要求我把节目做长。是的，我就是你的编辑罗曼，我可以证明这一点。你对我也太苛刻了。
I was so mean for 30, sucker. But podcasts have no constraints. You can be any length. The only constraint is the content. And people always tell me they wish this podcast was longer, but I think the show would suffer if it went on too long. And so maybe there's a need for a clock, even if the clock isn't strictly required.
对于 30 秒的内容，我确实很苛刻。但播客没有任何限制。你可以有任意长度。唯一的限制就是内容。人们总是告诉我，他们希望这个播客能更长一些，但我认为如果节目持续时间太长，品质就会受损。所以也许我们需要一个时钟，即使这个时钟并非严格必需。
Constraint, or maybe just restraint in this case, makes for better art. When I started thinking about the broadcast clock, as a piece of design, I wondered how it all got started in public radio. NPR came together in the late 60s and the early 70s when network news was king. And those broadcast shows, of course, had a clock. But public radio news wanted to be something different because of this guy. I'm Bill Seemoring and I was the first director of programming for NPR.
在这种情况下，限制，或者说克制，能造就更好的艺术。当我开始把广播时钟当作一件设计作品来思考时，我很好奇这一切是如何在公共广播中开始的。NPR 诞生于 60 年代末和 70 年代初，当时电视网新闻正处于鼎盛时期。那些广播节目当然都有时钟。但公共广播新闻希望有所不同，这要归功于这个人。我是比尔·西姆林（Bill Seemoring），我是 NPR 的第一任节目总监。
Bill Seemring and I was the first director of programming for NPR. Bill Seemring! Bill Seemring! He came up with the whole idea of all things considered, which of course everyone in the business now refers to as ATC. In the original mission statement, ATC was called a daily identifier or product. But you decided that wouldn't be a good name for the show going forward. Bill Seymourine was among the earliest designers of the public radio sound. That sound included lots of audio and voices from the world outside the studio.
比尔·西姆林，我是 NPR 的第一任节目总监。比尔·西姆林！比尔·西姆林！他想出了《综合报道》的整个创意，业内现在当然都把这个节目简称为 ATC。在最初的使命宣言中，《综合报道》被称为每日标识符或产品。但你决定这作为该节目未来的名字不太合适。比尔·西姆林是公共广播声音最早的设计者之一。这种声音包含了来自工作室外世界的的大量音频和声音。
And it called for a documentary style approach, even to same day news. For that, Bill designed a very open clock. We didn't have a lot of breaks throughout it, and it was this frustrated, some people, because they thought they wanted a very fixed clock. There was a clock, but it was not that tight. It was tight where we had joins with the stations, but otherwise it was not. And I think that's one of the things that made it interesting to listen to
它要求采用纪录片风格的方法，甚至对待同一天的新闻也是如此。为此，比尔设计了一个非常开放的时钟。我们在整个过程中没有设置很多间断，这让一些人感到沮丧，因为他们认为自己想要一个非常固定的时钟。这里确实有一个时钟，但它并没有那么紧凑。它在我们需要与电台连线的地方是紧凑的，但在其他地方则不然。我认为这是让它听起来很有趣的原因之一
because it wasn't predictable that way. And you let the stories, the stories were leading the length of the piece. The old ATC clock only had a few slices and a lot of open space. In there one story might be two minutes, followed by another that was 20 minutes. It was open.
因为它不是那种可以预测的。你让故事本身来主导稿件的长度。旧版的 ATC 时钟只有几个切片和大量的开放空间。其中一个故事可能是两分钟，接着是另一个 20 分钟的故事。它是开放的。
It was kind of like a podcast. But his bill was saying there. Not everyone appreciated that. There was a conference two weeks after ATC rolled out and the station manager just called Bill Seemring to the carpet for his fluffy loose sounding program. And there was something else that they really didn't like. And this is a digression here, but this is a podcast. So we get to have digressions.
它有点像播客。但正如比尔刚才所说。并不是每个人都欣赏这一点。在 ATC 推出两周后有一场会议，电台台长把比尔·西姆林叫去狠狠训斥了一通，指责他那蓬松、松散的节目。还有一件事是他们非常不喜欢的。这里扯远了，但这是一个播客。所以我们可以扯远。
And of course, I got this criticism from some about women's voices and all that stuff. That on FM women's voices had the high frequencies. And you should see the meter bill when women's voices come on and that kind of thing. Really, they said women's voices were too high for FM? Yeah. That some voices would peak the meter to. Oh my God. That kind of thing. Really? They said women's voices were too high for FM? Yeah.
当然，有些人对女性的声音等等提出过批评。他们在 FM 上说女性的声音频率很高。比尔，你真该看看当女性声音出现时的电平表之类的。真的吗？他们说女性的声音对于 FM 来说太高了？是的。有些声音甚至会让电平表爆表。哦天哪。诸如此类。真的吗？他们说女性的声音对于 FM 来说太高了？是的。
That some voices would peak the meter to us. Oh my God! The upshot Bill Seemreen was out of NPR a year and a half later. And in the years that followed, the NPR clock began a long process of becoming more subdivided. The women he hired, like Linda Worthheimer and Susan Stamberg are well known. Seamary went on to help turn fresh air with Terry Gross into a national program and he's the kind of the patron saint of creative open style public radio, including this program right here. But you know, being loose and open can also be its own form of pain. People often mention to me, you know, the boy,
有些声音甚至会让电平表爆表。哦天哪！结果就是，比尔·西姆林在一年半后离开了 NPR。在随后的几年里，NPR 的时钟开始了一个漫长的细分过程。他雇用的女性，如琳达·沃瑟海姆（Linda Worthheimer）和苏珊·斯坦伯格（Susan Stamberg）都非常知名。西姆林后来帮助将特里·格罗斯（Terry Gross）的《新鲜空气》（Fresh Air）打造成了一个全国性的节目，他可以说是充满创造力的开放式公共广播的精神教父，包括这里的这个节目。但你知道，松散和开放本身也可以是一种痛苦。人们经常对我提起，你知道，天哪，
those were the housey on days of all things considered and I was there, no they weren't. That's Neil Conan, who's done everything at NPR, including until recently, hosting the two-hour live call-in program talk of the nation. Neil Conan loves the clock. For him, it's an art form unto itself. There's these little things that if you've never done it or impossible, if you've done it forever, you don't even think about doing them. You know, how long is five seconds?
那是《综合报道》黄金美好的日子，而我当时也在场，不，根本不是那样的。这是尼尔·科南（Neil Conan），他在 NPR 做过所有事情，直到最近还一直在主持长达两小时的现场电话连线节目《全国话题》（Talk of the Nation）。尼尔·科南热爱这个时钟。对他来说，这是一门独一无二的艺术。有一些小事，如果你从来没做过，那是绝不可能做到的；如果你一直都在做，你甚至都不会去想怎么做。你知道，五秒钟有多长？
Five seconds is a long time. You can ID three guests and say goodbye in five seconds. So it's not surprising that when Neil Conan took over the talk of the nation, he added more time elements, more posts. Because it turns out you've said pretty much all you need to say about medical marijuana by the 40 and you should go on and do something else. Unfortunately, Neal Conan is doing something else now. NPR recently canceled talk of the nation after 21 years and he resigned.
五秒钟是很长的时间。你可以在五秒钟内介绍三位嘉宾并向大家道别。所以毫不奇怪，当尼尔·科南接手《全国话题》时，他增加了更多的时间要素和更多的卡点。事实证明，关于医用大麻，你基本上该说的在第 40 秒时都已经说完了，你应该继续做点别的。不幸的是，尼尔·科南现在正在做别的事。NPR 最近在《全国话题》播出了 21 年后将其取消，而他本人也辞职了。
Neal Conan says artificial constraints make us better. And I know this as a person who edits audio stories. We lose perspective when we're inside the story just trying to make sense of all our reporting. We can't tell what's important anymore. If we don't have any constraints, we can make boring and confusing stuff. The constraint doesn't have to be a time limit, but at least the clock forces us to have a perspective.
尼尔·科南说，人为的限制让我们变得更好。作为一个编辑音频故事的人，我深有体会。当我们身处故事内部，试图理清所有报道头绪时，我们会失去客观视角。我们再也分不清什么才是重要的了。如果我们没有任何限制，我们就会做出无聊且令人困惑的内容。限制不一定非得是时间限制，但至少时钟迫使我们保持视角。
It says, stop right there and figure out what really matters. Of course, the clock can also limit what you say, as we'll have to do in the broadcast version of this piece, or it can create nonsense where you suddenly at the full time you didn't expect to fill. So there was a day long ago when Neil Conan was not master of the clock. When he first started at NPR in the late 70s, he had a direct this new show called Weekend All Things Considered. I was being briefed on the clock by the then director of Weekend All Things Considered.
它在说，就在这里停下，弄清楚真正重要的是什么。当然，时钟也会限制你的言论，就像我们将在这段节目的广播版中所做的那样；或者它也可能制造出无意义的内容，让你突然有了意料之外的富余时间需要填补。所以，在很久以前的某一天，尼尔·科南并不是时钟的主宰。当他在 70 年代末刚开始在 NPR 工作时，他不得不导播这个名为《周末综合报道》（Weekend All Things Considered）的新节目。当时的《周末综合报道》导播正在向我介绍时钟。
Deborah Amos has gone on to summer and now is a reporter. And my question to her was, you mean exactly the time? And I think we ended that first show that I produced about four minutes early. I was so terrified of blowing the post. So a while ago I went to hear Deborah Ames speak. And afterwards I asked her if this story was true that Neil Conan ended his first live NPR show four minutes early.
黛博拉·阿莫斯（Deborah Amos）后来去过萨默尔（summer），现在是一名记者。我当时问她的问题是，你的意思是时间要分秒不差？我想我们制作的第一期节目大约提前了四分钟结束。我太害怕卡错点了。所以不久前我听了黛博拉·阿莫斯的演讲。事后我问她，尼尔·科南在他的第一场 NPR 直播节目中提前四分钟结束是否确有其事。
And she said they did. And that they had to grab the longest film music they could find in the studio, which was some kind of whale song. No super design, subdivided format is telling us when to stop this story. We're just kind of winging it. But you know, people in radio are always kind of winging it. Whether you're in a studio shed like mine, where I don't even think I have a clock in this room at all except for what's on the computer, or you're in the broadcast palace in DC with clocks everywhere.
她说确实如此。而且他们不得不在工作室里找一首能找到的最长的电影音乐，那是某种鲸鱼的叫声。没有超强的设计，细分格式来告诉我们什么时候该结束这个故事。我们只是在凭感觉即兴发挥。但你知道，广播界的人总是凭感觉即兴发挥。无论你是在像我这样的小工作室里，房间里甚至连个时钟都没有，只有电脑上的时间，还是在华盛顿特区到处都是时钟的广播殿堂里。
Okay, we have to do some adjustments, but they're good. Melissa, you have the line. We just hope someone out there is listening. Okay, see, disaster avoided. Yeah, she finished 45 seconds earlier. But they're not listening hard enough to hear the clock monster that haunts the dreams of anyone who's looked into its dark soul. Yeah, standby. Ready. Open. And all things Julia but hold Roman open for credits. And go. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Julia Barton, Sam Greenspan, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KALW in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco.
好吧，我们得做一些调整，但它们效果很好。梅丽莎，你的连线。我们只希望外面的某个人正在收听。好吧，看，灾难避免了。是的，她提前 45 秒结束了。但他们听得还不够仔细，听不到那个困扰着所有凝视过它黑暗灵魂之人的梦魇的时钟怪物。好的，待命。准备。开麦。所有人都在支持朱莉娅，但请留出罗曼的时间播放鸣谢。开始。本周的 99% Invisible 由朱莉娅·巴顿、山姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 以及旧金山美国建筑师协会的项目。
You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, I tweet at Roman Mars. Sam Greenspan, he tweets at Sam listens, even though he doesn't. Right now, on our brand new website, we have diagrams of broadcast clocks so you can say to your friends things like, I heard that during the eBlock of morning edition. Knowledge awaits at 99pi.org. All right, take it out. Let's go home. Radio Tepi-O.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注这个节目，我在推特上的账号是 Roman Mars。山姆·格林斯潘，他的推特账号是 Sam listens，尽管他根本不听。现在，在我们全新的网站上，有广播时钟的图表，这样你就可以对你的朋友说诸如“我听到那个是在《早间新闻》的 eBlock 期间播出的”这样的话。知识在 9pi.org 等着你。好了，收工。我们回家吧。Radio Tepi-O。
From PRX. Radio Tepi-R-X There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。Radio Tepi-R-X 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。